Laney took us to church with her
performance last night joining Alanis
Morissette and these ladies of country
singing You Oughta Know I'm usually so
solitary on stage so to be with women
next to me who are very very Soulful is
like being wrapped up and swaddled
[Applause]
performing with Alanis Morissette what
was going through your mind I mean first
of all I was thinking about that little
girl
Jumping on the Bed singing every word I
don't know and it was just a full circle
moment
Blake Shelton kicked off the show and
just before that he and Gwen Stefani
made their CMT Awards debut as a couple
on the carpet backstage Blake was his
wife's biggest fan before she performed
with Carly Pierce it's never going to be
the same around here again ever
feel out there with Gwen you guys killed
it oh my gosh it was so fun I love her
thank God for giving me you the night's
co-host Kane Brown and his wife Caitlin
were all about the PDA on stage and in
front of our camera they made history as
the first husband and wife Duo to take
home video of the year
that must not be a better feeling than
be able to do what you love with the
person that you love I couldn't ask for
anything more this is so special and
it's real every night I get to you know
sing this with her on tour every time I
see her it's like we uh we first met
it's like butterflies again you know I
love it every time we're loving this
double date night tonight you and Kane
Kelsey and Chase how much do we ship
those two I know I think we're gonna
hang out after the show tonight and
we're gonna have a lot of fun Kane's
hosting partner Kelsey ballerini hard
launched her relationship with Jay
Stokes last night the new lovebirds
posed on the carpet together and cuddled
up backstage inside the show Chase was
having a blast with his Outer Banks
co-stars Madison Bailey and Charles
Esten I've known Kelsey for years now
and of course I got to know Chase from
working with him and I just know what
sweethearts they both have I sort of
Texas
world's collide exactly oh this Outer
Banks love between you two we just met
but it looks like Kelsey and Madison
became Fast Friends Chase posted this
pic of the two getting cozy at the after
party Kelsey and Chase were among the
last to leave around 3 A.M Chase how
stoked are you to be here tonight
[Music]
until that's still that's Kelsey's
performance made a powerful statement
she played her new single with four drag
race Stars by her side taking a stand
against her home state of Tennessee's
anti-drag Bill how do you want fans to
know at home I love performance
hypothetically if you ever kill your
husband Kelsey made it really clear in
the rehearsal room she was like take up
that space I'm really thankful and
appreciative of that
foreign
Ona Judd returned to the CMT stage
alongside Ashley McBride this show was
the last place why sang with her mother
Naomi before her death you had a very
sweet moment
[Music]
well it's a year it's an anniversary and
not I went back and forth between
hitting a really high note and being a
diva or saying what was on my heart and
it took over and so here we are I want
to help people
it's like look at my face look at this
face
if you're having a crappy day and just
think if I can do it so can you because
it's not easy but I'm showing up
[Music]
Wynonna was part of the rocking All-Star
Leonard Skinner tribute that included
slash LeAnn Rimes and ZZ tops Billy
Gibbons Grammy winner Peter Frampton
made a rare public appearance using a
cane to introduce them four years ago he
announced his retirement after being
diagnosed with a degenerative muscle
disorder how about this performance uh
fantastic I mean how could it not be
it's all my favorite
more legendary performances Darius
Rucker performed with the black crows
and Gary Clark Jr honored the late
legendary guitarist and Austin native
Stevie Ray Vaughan
but this night belonged to jelly roll
the first time nominees a new face you
won't forget taking home the most Awards
three including male video of the year
you can be whatever you want to be I
promise you that I told him I wanted to
be a country music singer and I'm
standing here at the CMT Awards please
sweet baby we pulled the Hat Trick
Tonight boys you were very emotional in
your speech up there this is bigger than
just a single award for us dude we came
from nothing and how are we celebrating
tonight we're gonna get drunk real drunk
not kind of drunk I'm talking about old
school Honky Tonk kicked off Sixth
Street drunk y'all come on
[Applause]
[Music]